dès que les coudes et de clé à cliquet
et des clés spécifiques les grosses
voilà une partie des outils de travail
d'antoine martinez ce jeune yvelinois
est apprenti en mécanique automobile
une semaine sur deux ils travaillent
dans ce garage en alternance avec sa
formation au programme de la matinée la
révision d'une voiture accompagné par
son maître d'apprentissage
normand a le ton juste en face le trou
de la goupille il a fait la vidange
juste avant là et donne du coup on a
remis leurs armes ils bouchons
antoine martinez suit sa troisième année
de formation il passe actuellement son
bac pro maintenance des véhicules en
entreprise
il acquiert le savoir-faire le gérant de
ce garage lui transmet aussi les normes
de sécurité de qualité et le soin des
véhicules du client pour mettre des
housses dans la voiture se fera plus
propre depuis 11 ans cyril martinez
dirige ce garage il accueille souvent
des apprentis pour les former et les
embauches et ensuite un avantage non
négligeable pour ce chef d'entreprise
en fait il est formé un peu un peu à
notre manière un peu comme on a envie
que de devoir travailler en mécanicien
chez nous et point positif c'est que
déjà on peut alterner on peut être un
entre deux semaines on est payé on est
payé comme un comme un salarié mon
adhésion à des des salaires fixes pour
les apprentis quand il n'est pas en
entreprise antoine martinez dans son
centre de formation d'apprentissage la
fort pas situé sur le campus automobile
de guyancourt ce matin-là il a cours en
atelier sur des véhicules
objectif réaliser des diagnostics ont
créé des pannes sur les voitures et par
rapport à ces panneaux on donne aux
jeunes comme si on était on se
transforme ce ce jour-là en clients
entre guillemets pour le jeune en disant
ma voiture à tel problème et le jeune
recherche savane
au fur à mesure des procédures et on le
guide trouver la première fan déjà
enfant pas grand chose
c'était quoi la première fois
c'était un flic été coupée entre l'a1
entre le la sonde et le calculateur
on apprend à utiliser des outils qu'on
n'a pas forcément en entreprise
on apprend à utiliser subtilisé
multimètre ski et les hostiles aux scop
en 2019 la fort pas accueille deux cent
treize apprentis allant du ceap et au
bac et bts entre les cours classiques et
les activités en atelier l'objectif est
d'acquérir des compétences théoriques et
pratiques
l'apprentissage a est une est un format
de formation qui est très parlant avec
une insertion professionnelle assez
importante de l'ordre de 80 70 à 80%
un jeune en fait sortant du centre de
formation
obtient un travail dans les six premiers
mois alors je mens antoine martinez va
poursuivre sa formation jusqu'à la fin
de l'année et un examen final son projet
professionnel à terme ouvrir son garage
ou devenir mécanicien pour le sport
automobile